en file indienne les enfants de l'école
louise weiss a là ni les âmes attendent
patiemment leur tour pour entrer dans la
cantine avec la crise sanitaire la
restauration collective a dû s'adapter
et à plus de 17 des inflexions obligé on
fait attention en matto porte le masque
gestes-barrières l'étape sont
désinfectés les chaises aussi tout ce
que les enfants peuvent toucher on
remédie à ce que à ce que ce soit d un
facteur chaque fois à chaque passage
donc c'est vrai que c'est un travail
mais il faut le faire parce que c'est
pour le bien et la santé tout le monde
si les consignes sanitaires
gouvernementales sont respectés la
restauration collective et c'est
également de se réinventer
made in france alimentation plus saine
gestion des déchets les changements vers
une cantine 2.0 qui n'ont pas été freiné
par l'aco vide à magny les hameaux
la crise sanitaire
justifie finalement ce qu'on avait déjà
engagés auparavant avec plus de bio plus
plus d'action / sur la gestion du zéro
déchet et puis plus d'action aussi vers
vers le local et des produits locaux
tout ça donc on l'imaginait auparavant
on avait déjà entamé un certain nombre
d'actions
aujourd'hui très clairement on sait
quelle est la marche à suivre
les sociétés de restauration collective
et c'est aussi de s'adapter à la crise
elior par exemple qui possède un
restaurant d'entreprise à montigny le
bretonneux a développé le fameux click
and collect ou encore le self qui
s'emporte des tendances qui devraient
perdurer à l'avenir